this
is abraham maslow he is considered one
of the most important psychologists of
the 20th century
because of his association with the
famous hierarchy of human needs
this hierarchy depicts the idea that
human needs can be categorized into
different tiers
tier 1 includes physiological needs tier
2 includes safety needs
tier 3 includes belongingness and love
needs
tier 4 includes esteemed needs and the
final tier includes
self-actualization an interesting fact
however is that
maslow never really used the term
hierarchy to explain his theory
he merely suggested that there is a
causality between lower tier needs and
higher tier needs
by virtue of pre-potency most probably
the pyramid was an illustration designed
by one of his publishers
in order to offer to the reader a more
visual representation of maslow's ideas
in his three most important works
motivation and personality
toward the psychology of being and a
theory of human motivation
he delved deep into the topic of
self-actualization
a theme that attempts to overcome the
limitations of freud's psychoanalytic
theory
and introduce a new scope in the way
humans endeavor to actualize their
potential
he joined the branch of psychology
called humanistic psychology
that has its roots in phenomenology
existentialism
and eastern philosophy its main premise
is that
the ideas put forth by the traditional
psychoanalytic theory
are innately pessimistic and that this
constitutes an impediment in the way
humans progress through life
maslow was a positivist and a pragmatist
the basic framework of these theories
was that
only through a life devoted to personal
responsibility and constant
self-improvement
can an individual ever be truly happy a
catalyzing factor in the development of
his ideas was
the advent of world war ii that produced
so much
pain and suffering around the world he
firmly believed that humans regress to
more aggressive behaviors when their
path to self-actualization is vague or
obstructed by calamities that
disorient their true purpose his whole
journey through life
conducts an attempt to investigate the
ineffable mysteries of the psyche
through a focus on what can be done
rather than on what cannot be done
his work was an ostentatious but rather
it provoked thinking
via thorough analysis of the human
condition
most of his interest in this area
emerged from his examination of people
that
fulfilled the conditions of a
self-actualized person
he looked at people like albert einstein
and he saw figures that
met the standard of self-actualization
and could
act as archetypes for the rest of the
world in a way
abraham maslow can be considered the
forefather
of the contemporary self-development
movement
if we were to remove the biological
parameters from the equation
as well as every other trait that can be
bequeathed to a person from their
lineage
a human is a tabula rasa that is
one has the capacity to develop and
evolve to a state that one
truly desires insofar as one invests
heavily towards that state
according to maslow that state isn't
something obscure or elusive
after a lot of contemplation he came to
identify some major patterns that
repeat throughout instances of people he
called self-actualized
in the wake of extensive research he
formulated a framework of
self-actualization
that works as a great foundation for
personality development
in his seminal book motivation and
personality
he attempts to lay out the
characteristics of self-actualized
people
after a study he did on people who
according to him
met the criteria of self-actualization
these people were contemporaries of his
time
as well as important historical figures
the main characteristics that he
identified are as follows
the relationship between a person and
reality is a very intense one
reality constitutes an amalgamation of
known and unknown territory
thus rendering our perception of it
quite challenging
maslow argues that self-actualized
people embrace the unknown without fear
and that doubts doubt tentativeness
uncertainty
with the consequent necessity for
abeyance of decision
which is for most a torture can be for
some a pleasantly stimulating challenge
a high spot in life rather than a low he
also points out that people high
neuroticism
can actually distort their judgment and
even reality itself
because of their neurosis
here maslow puts emphasis on the idea of
responsibility and
to some extent stoicism self-actualized
people can accept their own human nature
in the stoic style
with all its shortcomings with all its
discrepancies from the ideal image
without feeling real concern it would
convey the wrong impression
to say that they are self-satisfied what
we must say rather is that
they can take the frailties and sins
weaknesses and
evils of human nature in the same
unquestioning spirit
with which one accepts the
characteristics of nature
that way acceptance can offer clarity to
one's perception
and allow one to make more sagacious
decisions
spontaneity simplicity and naturalness
all can lead to less artificiality in
the way one audience himself in the
world
as maslow points out a self-actualized
person's unconventionality
is not superficial but essential or
internal
it is his impulses thoughts
consciousness that are so
unusually unconventional spontaneous and
natural
apparently recognizing that the world of
people in which he lives
could not understand or accept this and
since he has no ways to
hurt them or to fight with them over
every triviality
he will go through the ceremonies and
rituals or convention
with a good humor shrug and with the
best possible grace
unconventionality in itself is a
somewhat puzzling trait
indeed a self-actualized person goes
through life with a critical attitude
but at the same time he or she won't
obsess over
unconventionality and constantly
experience friction
especially in trivial matters
our subjects are in general strongly
focused on problems outside themselves
in current terminology they are
problem-centered rather than
ego-centered they generally are not
problems for themselves and are not
generally much
concerned about themselves as contrasted
with the ordinary introspectiveness that
one finds in insecure people
the detachment from the ego when one
attempts to tackle a problem
constitutes a fundamental precondition
to effective problem solving
self-actualized people seem never to get
so close to the trees that
they fail to see the forest they work
within a framework of values that are
broad and not petty
universal and not local and in terms of
a century rather than the moment
the ability of an individual to seek and
enjoy isolation
is considered paramount in one's pursuit
of self-actualization
without a certain amount of seclusion
one cannot dive deep into complex ideas
and also develop
a significant level of self-discipline
self-decision and self-government
that however does not convey that the
self-actualized person is antisocial
but rather that he or she prefers to
invest in less superficial relationships
since they are propelled by growth
motivation rather than by
deficiency motivation self-actualizing
people are not dependent for their main
satisfactions on the real world
or other people or culture or means to
ends or
in general on extrinsic satisfactions
rather they are dependent for their own
development and continued growth
on their own potentialities and latent
resources
here maslow attempts to create an
interesting osmosis between the terms
autonomy independence will and action
taking
this attempt highlights a proclivity
towards a worldview that can help the
self-actualized person
maintain a relative serenity in the
midst of circumstances that would
usually make other people extremely
uncomfortable
gratitude is a virtue but throughout the
twists and turns of life
we end up forgetting how critical
gratitude can be in
appreciating all the little but
immensely beautiful things that life has
to offer
thus for such a person any sunset may be
as beautiful as the first one
any flower may be of breathtaking
loveliness
even after he has seen a million flowers
the thousandth baby he sees
is just as miraculous as a product as
the first one he saw
he remains as convinced of his lack in
marriage 30 years after his marriage
and is as surprised by his wife's beauty
when she's 60
as he was 40 years before for such
people even the casual work day or
moment-to-moment business of living can
be thrilling
exciting and ecstatic
apparently the acute mystic or big
experience
is a tremendous intensification of any
of the experiences in which
there is loss of self or transcendence
of it
the loss of self can lead to tremendous
revelations in the way our cognitive
apparatus
perceives different experiences and to a
certain extent
the world as a whole big experiences
have a mystical aspect and trends to
them
and they act as mechanisms that can
allow the self-actualized person
to transcend the ordinary in order to
connect with the sublime
according to maslow the word
mindshaftskyfield
invented by alfred adler is the only one
available that describes
well the flavor of the feelings for
mankind expressed by self-actualizing
subjects
this is a german word that roughly
translates to
sense of community our need for
identification
affection and sympathy is deeply
embedded in our constitution
and it is this need that drives our
desire for the pursuit of a greater good
in a nutshell gay mindsets describes the
capacity of the self-actualized human
to develop a vision bigger than himself
self-actualized people are capable of
more fusion greater love
more perfect identification more
obliteration of the ego boundaries than
other people would consider possible
here maslow is tapping into the
characteristic of self-actualized people
to
seek deeper connections in their
interpersonal relations
loyalty and a small dedicated circle are
favored over a plethora of shallow
connections
selectiveness can offer a sense of
clarity in our relationships
and also allow room for further
interpersonal
evolution
according to maslow self-actualized
people can be and are friendly with
anyone of suitable character
regardless of class education political
belief
race or color as a matter of fact it
often seems as if they are not even
aware of these differences
which are for the average person so
obvious and so important
the ability to not discriminate and to
adopt a more empathetic stance when it
comes to judging others
is a fundamental constituent of a
self-actualized personality
a certain degree of humility is required
to demonstrate such an attitude
as well as the proclivity to judge
people more by their character
and less by their status and racial
characteristics
the land that divides right from wrong
evil from good
and moral from immoral can oftentimes be
quite vague
our ability to make sane decisions when
we orient ourselves through
every social ecosystem is predicated
upon our capacity to understand the
importance of that vagueness
nothing is absolute and many truths can
be rebutted
self-actualized people understand that
well and try to act as
if their life is designed around that
idea moreover
self-actualizing people most of the time
behave as though
for them means and ends are clearly
distinguishable
in general they're fixed on ends rather
than on means
and means are quite definitely
subordinated to those ends
in that sense they're more likely to
appreciate the doing itself
for what it is regardless of the result
that it will lead them to
humor is a very debatable topic because
humor most of the time
is directed towards someone and this can
implicitly communicate the level of
hostility towards that someone
for self-actualized people things are
quite straightforward
as maslow points out characteristically
what self-actualized people consider
humor
is more closely allied to philosophy
than to anything else
it may also be called the humor of the
real because it consists in large part
in poking fun at human beings in general
when they are foolish or
forget their place in the universe or
try to be big when they're actually
small
this can take the form of poking fun at
themselves but this is not done in a
masochistic or clown-like way
lincoln's humor can serve as a suitable
example
probably lincoln never made a joke that
hurt anybody else
it is also likely that many or even most
of his jokes had something to say
they had a function beyond just
producing a love
they often seem to be education in a
more palatable form
akin to parables or fables
there is no limit to the degree one can
engage in creative work
creativity has an axiomatic character
and that can help push through any
mental barrier that
the thinking human may face it is as if
this special type of creativeness
being an expression of a healthy
personality is projected
out upon the world or touches whatever
activity the person is engaged in
in this sense there can be creative
shoemakers or carpenters or clerks
whatever one does can be done with a
certain attitude
a certain spirit that arises out of the
nature of the character of the person
performing the act
one can even see creatively as the child
does
maslow tries to shape the type of
thinking that self-actualized people
have maintained in order to
not allow cultural imperatives to define
their reality
cultural influence does have pros and
cons and therefore maslow argues that
in a world that attempts to impose
certain norms upon us
it is the duty of self-actualized people
to question those norms
reaching the stage of self-actualization
is not an easy thing
maslow attempted to portray the
archetype of the self-actualized person
by
collecting an amalgamation of
characteristics exhibited by people he
considered to be
the perfect representation of this
archetype as far as i am concerned
this constitutes a problem for he relied
on a very narrow group of people
in order to create an all-encompassing
narrative
that can make his case sound
epistemologically solid
indeed figures like benjamin franklin
and albert einstein are
celebrated by the whole of society as
individuals that achieved
remarkable things and whose personality
and attributes
we usually define as exemplary however
his choice of people seems elitist
and factors such as environmental racial
and biological influences haven't been
taken into account
in order to understand how easy it is
for someone
to reach a self-actualized state in the
grand scheme of things the possibility
that such characteristics can be
attained by anyone seems utopian to say
the least
to dwell within the boundaries of this
utopian pursuit
is to inhabit a space whose intellectual
topography
is modeled almost entirely from
ambitious assertions
and the purpose of these assertions is
to reinvent the meaning of our lives
self-actualization isn't the end but
self-actualization isn't a delusion
either
it is none and both at the same time we
can call it a mechanism
it's a mechanism that acts as a compass
whenever the moral
intellectual and intuitive processes
that orient us towards what is good for
us
are out of sync and this happens far too
often
the chaotic nature of reality leaves no
room for alternatives
but such an endeavor regardless of how
demanding it seems
can be within our reach the person who
wants to be self-actualized
believes that they are worthy of
self-actualization
and it is so because they make it so
as it is mentioned in toward the
psychology of being
abraham maslow doesn't pretend to have
easy answers
absolutes or solutions that bring the
relief of finality
but he does have a deep belief in people
self-actualization constitutes a vision
for humanity
and should be treated as such our
constitution is fluid and
it is this fluidity that allows us to
constantly innovate in the way
we approach our relationship with
ourselves and with each other
ontological questions grow our appetite
for life
and through an interplay between the
known and the unknown we will always
define
our mode of being and become more
enamored with the machinations of the
cosmos
it is this interplay that will define if
and when
we can only reach this fascinating state
that is self-actualization
hey guys so this video is sponsored by
skillshare
skillshare is an online learning
community with thousands of inspiring
classes
for creative and curious people i have
been using skillshare extensively to
learn new skills and to peer into the
minds of other
great creators and since we were
discussing self-actualization
in this video i think it is the duty of
a self-actualized person to
never stop learning and to keep pursuing
the exam in life
skillset is a great tool that can help
you do that
the classes included in the platform are
quite diverse
and they're also curated in a very
structured and
appealing way i liked so many classes
but the ones that stood out for me are
definitely
real productivity how to build habits
that last by thomas frank
and also the one called productivity
master class
principles and tools to boost your
productivity by
ali abdom both guys are youtubers that i
follow and
they have created two amazing classes
that can really re-engineer the way you
view
productivity the first class will help
you structure your life in a way
that will allow you to rely on systems
rather than
on abstract practices and really build
habits that last
the second class will help you debunk
some widely circulated productivity
myths
and eventually get to the gist of proper
productivity practices
skillshare is curated specifically for
learning meaning that
there are no ads and they're always
launching new premium classes so you can
stay focused and
follow wherever your creativity takes
you and it's less than ten dollars a
month with an annual subscription
so the first thousand of you to click
the link in the description
below we'll get a free trial of premium
membership so you can explore your
creativity
enjoy again thanks for watching see you
soon adrian out